good morning believe nation today's
message is there is no overnight success
over to you Gary Vaynerchuk nothing in
life is free nothing happens overnight
it all takes tons and tons of work and
tons and tons of talent and tons and
tons of serendipity but my friends luck
serendipity there's a forced culture
within that you know you don't just sit
in your room hoping and then something
lucky happens nobody just knocks on your
houses door and says congratulations
you've been awarded this luck comes from
being in the right spot I've been really
lucky he's gonna bleed out of my eyes
every day of my life and work my face
off you get really lucky when you have
that 11:30 p.m. meeting and we're the
lucky thing happens pretty cool since
all you were sleeping I was pretty lucky
weird that I scheduled that meeting
because I did a ton of things for 30
years that allowed me to even have that
meeting in the first place that gave me
the leverage to have that lucky thing to
happen
there's no overnight successes period
they don't exist show me leave a comment
YouTube leave the name explain to me
tell me show me let me know show me the
overnight success because I'll show you
you justifying in your brain something
that is just not period so I was
chatting with a friend of mine named car
the other day and Kai is a League of
Legends
streamer and she's a student and I was
asking her hey how you doing a league
you know are you climbing the ranks what
he doing and right now she's a she's in
platinum I like to play league good I'm
only in silver I'm silver 3 the way it
works is bronze silver gold and a
platinum diamond I don't know diamond
go ahead challenger and then you're
basically a professional there's a big
gap between where I am at silver 3 and
where Chi is at platinum and the CHEO
balcony said yeah but you're way ahead
of me on YouTube and it's true and it's
a reflection of where we're both
spending our time because as much as I
love League League has never been a huge
ambition for me it's never been you know
me wanting to be one of the greatest
League of Legends players in the world I
love it I spend a semi-regular amount of
time playing it but it's never something
I put an insane amount of energy and
love into I put that kind of love into
my youtube channel right I'm reviewing
videos I'm answering comments I'm
researching the next thing we're putting
out 3 videos a day I'm sitting here
filming that taking up time during my
day to do it you know setting that the
lights got the camera I spent an insane
amount of time because Hilden I love to
do and you see the results and kind is
the same thing for her League of Legends
right she spends a time to get better
she streams that she works out and she
practices that she drills and that's why
she's in diamond and I'm in silver 3 and
that's why I have a hundred fifty
thousand subscribers plus in my youtube
channel and I don't know how many she
has but it's not close where you spend
your time is where you gonna get results
and neither of us if you look at us have
been an overnight success in our
categories now we put our blood our
sweat our hustle our tears our energy
our resources our creative spark into
making what we do come alive and I hope
you do the same thing in your business
so the question of the day today is do
you think that there is such a thing as
an overnight success leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events fresco